hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to alien isolation the
autosave dropped me off a bit before but
if you remember we just got to the point
where I believe things are going to be
happening I had to step out before I had
to play this again but I'm very eager to
get back into it I mean I love space so
much but I enough fangasm in about space
I remember that happen before why did it
make me jump again
could I get some lights back on because
I really can't see anything you did not
give me any sort of flashlight hello I'm
actually playing this at night now and I
changed up the lighting in my office
here if you guys could tell what is this
a medical Bay why is there a body bag
right there this doesn't exactly seem
like a sanitary Hospital so I'm going to
assume that things are going bad what
have you got for me I'm getting such
dead space pods oh I've already gotten
here sorry backtracking I forgot what
I've already covered I already went in
here it's just a little bit darker than
I remember before I'm gonna pay
attention a bit more because I felt like
because I had wasted time on the
original part trying to look for the
damn terminal I'm gonna be very more
careful about my environment so that I
actually pay attention and not miss
anything which is definitely something
that I'm prone to doing but I definitely
don't need to rush this entire process
here because there's a lot of detail in
this obviously it's a really pretty game
there's a lot of cool stuff to look at
so I'm gonna look at it with both
eyeballs as okay hello who I'm gonna
look at you with both eyeballs okay
nevermind time to wrap up need to go oh
is that a workbench is that some blue
hey who's crawling around there there
that distinctly sounded like alien
breathing at least as far as I remember
it's been a while it's so dark and they
just never gonna give me a flashlight is
that what's gonna happen here I'm just
gonna be perpetually wandering around in
the darkness until I find out that the
dude is directly in front of my face and
he's got about to rip it off with his
small mouth inside his mouth so
everything is locked down here I need to
go the way that I just opened after
activating the power such that I would
be able to find my way out of here wait
a minute wait a minute but that doesn't
make any sense I just went through here
it's just open this gate up didn't it
I'm not going crazy I might that's
exactly what that did well I don't see a
maintance jack and every time I go to
that door noises start appearing
throughout the rest of the complex
assuming something doesn't want me over
there oh wait this is I'm sorry did I
interrupt or what is that those Lazar's
oh that's blood
oh no that's not blood what is that what
what was that blood
who's that streams of blood I don't know
what that was it's dark and everything
is Linton blitt by luminescence
something no see oh that's a bad word
sir or madam okay then all right I'll go
in here I am no looter please do not
kill me dead why would I hide I know
exactly why I just in case it was a
monster trying to nibble my giblets come
on save yes I do want to do that does
that mean that there's gonna be monsters
pretty soon I'll imagine the only reason
you would want me to hide is just there
to be something hard Oh fun stuff went
through here what did someone burst at
us up
did something burst out of someone's
chest so dark was I supposed to get like
a flashlight early on and I just missed
it is that what this game is all about
was it just designed to be this way so
that there's only enough light to kind
of know where I'm going
seems like some sort of storage oh hello
bad word is that what I need is that the
master Jack how do I get that I want
that who did that
oh I didn't see that how was I supposed
to see that pitch blackness yeah I know
that I should turn up the brightness but
I looked in the options I can't find
where the setting is I guess I'm just
stuck this way huh going on why is
everything sparking that's a no like oh
that's blood
yep that's blood I'm gonna assume that
every time I think there's blood there's
blood blood everywhere
I am what oh there we go okay I wasn't
sure exactly what I was supposed to do
there I got tripped up because I pressed
both the buttons and I pressed a so
apparently that guy had a fun time
before he died that was good to know
pardon is that blood
oh no that's water why is there water
why would there just be water leaking
around on a space station doesn't seem
healthy wait did I somehow cycle back to
exactly where I was before I don't know
if that was the case or at least I can
remove these braces now I have a feeling
like that's good maybe but that means
that I can progress to places that I
shouldn't go and that means bad stuff
oh they're gonna do an ice breaker on
him huh
Annie breaker a ball breaker and then an
ice breaker so I need to go back to the
other place in disabled the jacket there
are a lot more bodies than I originally
remember seeing I don't know there's
gonna be dead space and they're gonna
take the bodies away I think that alien
Xenomorphs need a live body to be able
to do their chest bursting magic trick
but I'm not sure about that maybe that's
just a rumor
maybe I don't know everything yeah I'm
so strong I also got a cool calculator
watch cuz I'm just a badass like that I
don't know I haven't been trying to
communicate with my fellow teammates
I guess I'm assuming that they didn't
make it across but I have a feeling that
I'm gonna find mr. robot man and miss
legal lady down the road later wait was
that it oh I thought this was a crafting
bench but then again I guess I can craft
anywhere I need to in fact I'm pretty
sure I can craft a medkit no I don't
have enough stuff I have the other
things but not compound B whatever the
hell that is so I need to find other
stuff but I think that was the only
thing that was over here so I can head
back
possibly and open the side door there
unless there was another door those
might have been but I don't know if they
were just locked off or they were
actually bolted up we just double check
real quick I don't wanna miss out on
anything
now all those are definitely locked up I
shouldn't be here I should just move on
hello noises in the darkness are you
gonna come out and kill me stab me
through the chest implant a baby through
my esophagus that would be nice
how's moving did I just step on a body
is that the crunch I heard oh it's a
cutscene why I'm still okay okay all
right
Irish guy or Scottish guy I'm really
where'd you come from Ripley I've
stationed [ __ ] there's no ships here
uh-huh
there are now well that's good news
because things are not so good here
something blue just no rock this whole
place Oh
Oh lady that's the least of our problems
yeah something you wouldn't believe it
you get it okay okay what's your name
max I was boarding with two colleagues
uh-huh
EBA we got separated by the blast can
you help me find them
could you put the gun down cuz you seem
to know your way around why what's in it
for me
a place on the ship I know I can trust
you I need to find comms I need to
contact my ship
yay friends it seems like it then again
I could have never come on this ship I'm
sure I trust this guy he seems like a
stand-up gentleman I'm sure that he's
not alluding who are you
I'm John this is Ringo what's your small
holes for this come on Jenna we're
trying to get to comms can you help us
we don't need their help
don't tell them anything look I've got
the elevator working
Jana let's go okay I I'm sorry good luck
okay bye have fun not dying even though
you probably will die very soon to an
alien ripping out your face it is dark
why are you so damn aggressive why oh
yes of course the old horror movie motto
whenever something goes horribly wrong
in this monsters about to rip your face
off split up
remove all semblance of society and just
go on your own way it'll be better that
way easier for the killer well it flies
through space so how about that it goes
and then it gets you up from space
that's how hold up human technology gets
to going human technology is summed up
in just a special touch sure I bet you
got a real special touch there axel
where'd you call yourself Jacob Jamison
the button you got it ha oh sorry I
meant to hit that much harder
Bing bong Bing Bing keep the noise down
here there might be people around it's
only just now I need to know what's
going on right [ __ ] now like I said
there's a killer what does that even
mean I ain't seen it but it's here yeah
and now that you've mentioned it I'm
finally gonna see it and you're gonna be
the first to die anyway I'm just gonna
hope that you're the first to die I
think that's how this is gonna go it's
controlled what boosts oh I'm down were
way off
are you crazy there's no what did you
did you at least we're safe down here
for how long
what if they come for us and we shoot
the crap out of them
now shut up you're making me nervous
uh-huh well good job you made them
nervous
hoping an alien doesn't come by will you
have a gun shoot them both let's take
our guns oh do I get to look at your
butt as we crawl through here oh man you
are not a handsome man
okay got it can I can I please thank you
yes
[Music]
they don't like strangers even nice guys
like me I'm shocked
come here Jane now you want to go and
say hello it's your funeral who's got
something for sure someone should be
doing something they are
it's called surviving I'd like to think
humans would be better than just to
totally devolve into little cells and
then whole parts of the ship's know up
and everyone hates each other you've got
what you need
probably never because I'm gonna grab
everything that you have and then your
old compound be I needed that yeah
thanks for putting your gun to my head
it can get any darker around here you
should take that flashlight
finally if where is it where it where's
this it's so dark I can't see the
flashlight where it where is this where
is the flashlight sir there it is okay
that's a flashlight what oh it's a
head-mounted flashlight okay
just be careful not to flash at a time
we don't want to get caught
let's go I'm holding Neff oh oh that is
literally the worst flashlight I've ever
seen in my life
can I save it this one I don't know if I
did Aaron let's continue on I'm getting
very dead space last week half-life
vibes from all this growling Invents fun
well now that you're escorting me around
why do you mean you don't know where it
is that's really gonna be helpful why do
I have to find it why can't I watch your
vent I mean is now gonna be a bit more
helpful if I hey is this it it looks a
little gonna kill us but it's got a red
ring around it probably means blood red
dead right it was here somewhere
see got it covered yeah I'm sure you
first where'd you go oh there you are
keep disappearing on me come on
something's gonna kill him I know
something gonna kill him he ain't gonna
last
Axl you're not getting off this ship
alive you finally been surviving on your
own someone like me comes along promises
you a ship you start venturing off being
unsafe just want to stay alive it's
alright cuz I think this tunnel is the
exact same size as a sea no more yeah
you got it yeah I hear ya will do gotta
go meet the others something's going
down there's always something going down
come on we want to piss him off who's
him where'd you go
oh I didn't know there was a hallway
here never mind then I thought for sure
okay hi Axl what do you got limp or is
that your sneaked walking you got it
just give me a flashlight and then never
let me use it
hello sir ah huh
oh come on someone will switch the
emergency someone else has been here
everyone stay alert keep your guns tight
shoot anyone you don't know good policy
stick around while I check our stock too
many of them at econ
we still got to get through there the
door at the end oh yeah that seems right
so where is this generator a generator
over there is that an arrow pointing up
I'm not exactly sure but I'm gonna guess
over there what's up help yourself a
little what the [ __ ] is that supposed to
mean
hey he's been with me the whole time
we're missing food amal meant if it's
not one of us then we were right
someone's been in here this is no good
we're supposed to be secure down here
okay that's where I am it's pointing
okay then so it's on the other side
sorry I got mixed up that was my bad I
apologize eyes open keep your guns ready
someone's gonna have to tell the boss
boss is a goddamn store clerk yeah maybe
you think you could do better
he's not saying that I'm just saying
that just stop saying
and help me check the rest of this stuff
huh if you could keep your trap from
running for five seconds right good to
know there's a lot of cooperation going
on even in the scum of the universe Bing
bong
[Music]
so I guess I can go down here now no
one's gonna know no one will ever know
where am I going where am I going what
am i doing we're here we go perfect okay
help this is safe it's better be safe
whoa whoa okay
all right then wait what am i suppo oh I
see okay I'm following this different
start than I thought it was gonna be but
I got to remember that in these [ __ ]
situations
I guess humans are a very significant
enemy they actually are just pieces of
crap most of this I'm bing-bong thank
you very much I'm wondering if like
those terminals are the only time that
it's gonna save my game I haven't had
much luck either well the way where'd
you go axel axel buddy my good friend oh
there you are are you doing
okay fine Holly jeez sure oh yeah I'm
sure no I'm supposed to be here my
shipping out papers were for a week ago
oh so he's a week from retirement this
guy is so dead - man rule oh sure -
thank you - a two-man rule like this
means it needs to to open the door
saddle tables from two different
consoles okay all right then that seems
good trust no one
ah good thing I got two people with me
right now that seems important well
alright then so they're low on food and
supplies but I don't need those cuz I'm
a video game character
I don't eat until it's a cutscene I
don't have any feelings until its
cutscene
I don't do nothing unless it's a
cutscene Oh restore power
yeah souls of Kossoff oh come on
God we need to activate both consoles at
the same time to open it I'll do this
one you go to the one on the other side
oh yeah oh yeah sure you're just not
gonna run off without me huh we're gonna
get somehow separated it's gonna be so
much fun on three one two three
bonk sorry I was slightly delayed dude
down that you know that didn't really
look like it hurt okay alright then that
was loud good job there axel I'm sure
you survived a long time without I'll
stop looking down on run don't shoot me
no he's just sleep and check him again
Oh Oh cutscene done you killed that guy
yeah cuz he was going to kill me you
saved my life
this survival understand No
oh yes
plant it all over the walls I think I
should probably not stay here yeah well
I'm sure it'll leave me alone now is
gonna be beaten for a while it'll be
fine
Oh got a key move and don't tell me what
I need to do because I'm gonna end this
episode here so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done we're just
getting into the nitty-gritty of it
Balian is showing space and we're about
to get in the deep scares here haha so
I'll see you in the next week
[Music]